Donald Trump's PR campaign of telling
people how he's going to save jobs or
bring jobs back to America has had some
embarrassing setback so remember that
shortly after the election Donald Trump
got Mike Pence to basically abuse his
power as Indiana governor to offer a 7
million dollar tax break to the
air-conditioning company carrier so that
they wouldn't outsource or lay off
workers and at the time I told you this
is not really economic policy giving a
one-off tax break to one company for PR
purposes is anti free market it's not
replicable across the entire economy and
we later found out that carrier was
actually going to use the money that
they were going to get to automate their
factory over the medium term and in the
long run it was actually still going to
kill jobs and Trump this fell for it
hook line and sinker they loved it and I
told you at the time again and again
it's bogus it's not policy it's nothing
remember when the right said that Barack
Obama shouldn't be picking and choosing
winners it turns out that Donald Trump
has basically done the same thing and it
has failed miserably the carrier factory
in Indianapolis that we're talking about
that we've been talking about is going
to be laying off more than 600 workers
over the next month and Donald Trump
bragged about saving like a thousand
jobs at carrier we later learned it was
only about 700 jobs and now 600 of those
jobs that donald trump supposedly saved
are going bye-bye
in addition to that carrier is planning
to send a separate thirteen hundred more
jobs to Mexico Chuck Jones president of
United Steelworkers one 999 in Indiana
tried to warn us about this when Donald
Trump did this in December remember when
he said quote I've been doing this job
for thirty years what I can't abide is a
president who misleads workers who gives
them false hope company leaders are
racing to the bottom to find places
where they can pay the least Donald
Trump responded to that by tweeting
Chuck Jones who's president of United
Steelworkers 1999 has done a terrible
job of representing workers no wonder
companies leave the country oh the irony
Chuck Jones received death threats as a
result of what Donald Trump tweeted
about him and it turns out that Chuck
Jones was exactly and totally right and
in addition to factory workers who were
fed this BS line of false promises
Indiana taxpayers should also be upset
about this this is not fiscally
conservative at all it's government
bailouts which I thought they were
against which have failed yeah I mean
obviously you can't scale this you can't
just give every company a seven million
dollar tax credit that threatens to
leave the United States or layoff
workers but it was also one of those
things that you would kind of give Trump
a little bit of a win on because he said
he was going to save those jobs and it
looked like he had turns out that's not
the case not at all and it gets even
worse back in February Donald Trump held
one of these post campaign campaign
rallies at a Boeing plant in South
Carolina the airplane manufacturer and
he put on a big show talking about save
jobs at Boeing yada yada yada remember
when he did this because when American
workers win America as a country wins
big league wins that's my message here
today America is going to start winning
again winning like never ever before
sadly Boeing said over the weekend that
that particular plant is going to be
laying off 200 workers recall that
Donald Trump said at the rally my focus
has been all about jobs and jobs is one
of the primary reasons I'm standing here
today as your president and I will never
ever disappoint you this is more sad
than anything else
I mean Trump's deal-making approach is
number one not suited for politics but
it's also hurting people and wasting
money the truth is it's not easy to
bring manufacturing jobs back to the US
Automation is a big factor we've talked
about the other issues and
mega-corporations usually write the laws
that politicians sign in exchange for
kickbacks and bribes and you really
would need mega corporations to
fundamentally upend the way that they've
been increasing profits in order to
bring manufacturing jobs back to the US
if those
jobs even exist we need a paradigm shift
on this and I don't think we're going to
get a paradigm shift on it anytime soon
today's episode of the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS